hello everyone we'll be starting with
today's workshop
at the scheduled time
in five more minutes thank you for
joining
meanwhile we begin with today's workshop
it would be great if you could please
introduce yourself in the chat box and
tell us about your research background
your research interests and what are you
working on
thank you
i would like to welcome those i've just
joined the session
we'll be starting in few more minutes we
are waiting for others to join as well
thank you for joining
and meanwhile we begin with today's
session it would be nice if we could
hear from you in the chat box about your
uh educational background or your
research work and what is your research
and trust
a very warm welcome to all of you
present here
after concluding two successful
workshops on genomic surveillance of
sars scope to variants of concerned
reporting and ngs single cell data
analysis and scrna project support we
are here with another
brainstorming workshop on machine
learning for ngs data analysis
today we are going to cover practical
and conceptual aspects of data
exploration statistical analysis and
machine learning in application to high
throughput biomedical data using r and
python
throughout the workshop participants
will get an understanding of supervised
and unsupervised machine learning in the
context of curated projects and coding
challenges that illustrate methods
applications and theory
it is designed as a combination of
online resources practical assignments
and live workshops that will be
conducted online
we will also review several project
examples that demonstrate successes and
limitations of conventional machine
learning methods and deep learning using
data
from public repositories
the page participants of this workshop
will be getting the access to the
resources that i will be explaining in
few slides
so before we begin with today's workshop
let me introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with number of
organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
the research-based training programs are
a result of close collaboration between
pine biotech and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation curriculum review and
project design
omix launch of training has been
completed by over 15 000 participants
from 162 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
the omixlogic training follows a
project-based learning approach using
research great tools to analyze data
from top peer reviewed journal
the training has been completed and is
undergoing in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
honored to introduce the founders and
the team members of the company dr ashar
tober comes from from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of the
topper bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brotzky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right julia panna who was an expert by
informaticium
abby tatevsky leads the development of
the tbi info platform dr mohit madhumdar
is an experienced bioinformatician with
multiple publications in peer
reviewed journals
and project need for omixojic training
and research fellowship
is an accomplished computational
biologist with an experience in large
scale analysis of multi-orgs data and
data science methods in precision
oncology and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
and my name is sunali khari and i'm the
only logic community manager and i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users who are a part of a
community managed by fine powder
so now let's gear up for today's session
first of all all of you need to sign up
on the omixlogic learn portal that will
give you the access to the omnilogic
courses which includes courses on
bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python an
example project of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
your research for
users will be given directions to access
the tbi info platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of transactomics
data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
so now let's go to the learn.org logic
portal and sign up quickly and then
we'll be starting with the workshop
signing up on the portal will help you
get the access to the resources that we
are going to go through today
let me share my screen
those who have already signed up on the
omnislogic learn portal please let me
know in the chat box by putting in a one
or yes maybe so that i know that you are
all ready to get started with the
workshop and those who have not yet
signed up
uh quickly go to the link that is
present here in the chat box and sign up
so that we can get started
and thank you ambrain for introducing
yourself and telling us about your
background
[Music]
okay so now how do you sign up let me
give you a quick demo to all of you
present here
i'm going to re-login for you all
now when you click on the login button
you can create an account for yourself
just by putting in your details that are
asked or simply sign up with any of your
social media accounts i'll be doing it
with one of my google accounts
i'm awaiting responses in the chat box
to begin with today's session so that i
know that we all are ready with the
resources in hand
thank you for watching for your response
okay so those who have signed up on the
portal they can click on their mail
address that will redirect them to the
profile tab now in this profile section
you will be able
to look at your profile where you will
be you you can monitor your progress
of various courses that you are taking
and also you will be able to download
your certificates
in the profile section you are supposed
to update your profile picture
you should ensure that you have your
name in title case having your name
entitled case you will make sure that
the name that comes in the certificate
is in the right format please connect
your social media accounts and add a
brief file about yourself that could
include about your research background
or educational background if you're a
student and what are your research
interests so that we know about you and
can align your interests accordingly
so now let's get started with today's
workshop i'll now like to pass on the
stage to dr raghavendra and those who
have signed up uh it's good for them
those who have not can sign up in in a
while and follow along the resources
will sir so over to you dr raghav
yeah actually um i'll be starting
someone accountable like when you
discuss okay i'm so sorry yeah uh
all right so um thank you everyone for
joining today um let me make sure i'm
showing yeah can everybody see my screen
yes yeah we can see your screen
all right
okay so um today i will start by giving
an
introduction telling you briefly about
what we do and how
you can kind of benefit from
what we do on a regular basis today is
an example and it's really designed for
people that are going to be applying
some of these methods to a data set so
what we will try to cover today is a
little introduction to omex logic as a
community
and as a
resource that you can leverage either
for doing research learning about
different methods of analysis or helping
others so if you're a faculty member
or you
are teaching maybe a teacher
these are resources that you can
leverage and so
today's session is actually an
extraction from a
program that we run regularly
this program right now is ongoing for
louisiana biomedical research network
and for members of the national
association of idea principle
investigators and this program is
typically conducted as a three months
course
where we introduce statistical analysis
and machine learning methods we talk
about how to design experiments and how
to validate the findings and we talk
about how to apply different types of
methods of machine learning like data
mining and
different ways to apply supervised
machine learning like classification
network analysis and others
so the program typically addresses
several different important issues with
uh machine learning so a lot of the work
to get data prepared for machine
learning is an important part of knowing
how to deal with different types of
structured and unstructured data
it is important to understand the
difference between signal and noise and
for that purpose we have a number of
exercises that are applied to different
types of omics data which i will explain
in detail today and then we talk about
this challenge of data complexity or big
data volume complexity
heterogeneity and how machine learning
really helps us to
extract meaningful
insights from such data sets and learn
about the links between biology and data
so how to really
get some insights from such data
so who is this for these programs that
we design are really
made
in such a way that anyone that has
minimal background
in data science can benefit from such
programs and today i hope will be an
example of how anyone with
just kind of basic understanding of some
of these topics can get
much further ahead can really learn and
practice and get some practical
experience with uh these complex methods
and so
hopefully after today's session you will
kind of see
as a perspective into the data science
and machine learning
how this can apply also for other
methods and other types of data
so the goal of my part of the session is
to really talk about
the need for data science and machine
learning for biologists i mean why is it
an important topic what are some of the
important things to consider
how to use it in your research in your
publications if you're just getting
started how to get started
i will also talk about some of the
challenges with the type of data that
you are commonly going to encounter and
i will explain our approach of teaching
bioinformatics to explain how you can
quickly go from raw unstructured data to
something that you can use and then in
the second part of this presentation uh
raghav will explain how you can actually
practice and practically analyze such
data using some examples
we will also talk about the logic behind
the analysis and introduce the resource
that helps uh kind of structure the
logic in a
in a way that you can follow and
practice more
and then we will talk about some of the
bigger challenges with machine learning
specifically
why it's important to understand the
methods in detail and not only learn how
to run them so why is it important to
understand the meaning behind the
different settings or being able to
explain and validate some of the
findings
that you have done using machine
learning
so let's start by briefly introducing
data science and kind of talking about
where machine learning fits in into this
more broad topic of data science how
does this relate to biological and
biomedical data
so commonly what you will find is that
data science is described as the
intersection of
data statistics
and some specialization domain so we can
talk about
data storage
data formats how to manipulate data we
can talk about different analytical
methods like hypothesis testing and then
typically there's a domain that you
apply these tools to and so in each one
of these
you can distill them into these specific
challenges
for analysis it is difficult difficulty
of extracting signal
from noisy data sets
for data we'll talk about the
differences between structured and
unstructured data and the challenges of
making data structured so that you can
easily apply analysis methods to them
and then for specialization domain in
every domain whether it be biological
research or financial modeling the
importance is annotation and validation
so understanding some data is more
intuitive than others and in the
biomedical or biological domain we need
to rely on annotation and validation
using databases
bioinformatics is typically described as
the intersection of statistical analysis
informatics and biology and so
really what it is is the application of
data science to the biological domain
and in this biological domain we have
several different applications like
basic research
biotechnology agriculture genetics
biomedicine etc etc
so really when we look at the two of
these together we can kind of see that
the intersection really only changes by
specialization so biology is more
specific
for bioinformatics and data science is
just more agnostic
and so the question is how does machine
learning fit into this scheme so machine
learning is really the intersection of
statistics and mathematics and computer
science and machines in this case are
algorithms or models that we can train
and they rely on statistical methods and
principles right in reality many of the
things that we call artificial
intelligence and machine learning they
leverage a lot of the statistical
analyses that have been around for a
long time what has changed are the
advances in computational infrastructure
and
as a result of that some of the things
that were not possible previously are
now possible
and so machine learning sits at the
intersection and really what we're going
to be talking today as
machine learning for biological and
biomedical data are the sub
kind of
portions of machine learning which are
unsupervised machine learning supervised
machine learning methods deep learning
explainable and interpretable right how
do we actually take these models analyze
using these models complex data sets and
then know how to explain them know how
to apply them properly and validate that
what we're finding is really true signal
and not noise
so to begin
speaking about this i think we need to
start from talking about data
so
why is it called data science and why
does machine learning fall under data
science so data typically comes
as
a collection of
you know some kind of digital signal and
data science is the study of the signal
and so when we talk about data
majority of the data that you will find
is actually unstructured and so the
first
90 percent of your time that you're
going to be spending with data is really
converting this unstructured data to
structured data which is a table or a
matrix or a data frame
and once you do that you want to find
associations in this data and there are
going to be many associations in the
data some of them relevant and some of
them not and so studying associations
within that data are typically going to
result in some kind of a model
and that model is what we will
talk about today how to differentiate
between these models and how to then
extract from these models some meaning
so
the process
from unstructured data to maybe
semi-structured data where you have
many different components and you are
trying to understand relationships
between them to then finally structure
data and that structured data is
something that now is going to be easy
for you to analyze and extract some
meaningful relationships and those are
going to be what we will talk about
today because they should be reportable
and actionable
now one of the major trends in
biomedical research and biological data
is the exponential growth of data that
is now available for anyone to access
and so what we will do today is we will
take a few examples on these data sets
but as you will find it's very easy to
find data
in fact in just this pandemic we just
kind of did this
chart at the beginning of the pandemic
and we found that the number of genomes
submitted during this pandemic is
many times more than in previous
pandemics that have been recorded and in
particular this is because
data generation is cheaper more
accessible and more useful and so
machine learning is especially important
because now we are able to collect data
very quickly and this data is large and
unstructured so when we talk about
genomes for example these are nucleotide
sequences and so it's not easy to
analyze the sequences why well to
explain why i have this
very brief example so here's an example
of unstructured data on one hand and how
we tend to look at data to be able to
interpret it so unstructured data in
this case is an example for a chat
an exchange on chat
so you can see that we have a date
we have different names here of users
and we have their responses and these
are responses to questions so for
example if i ask the question what is
your degree what is you know your
highest level of education
any person here can answer in multiple
different ways someone will say i have a
bachelor's someone will say i have a
master's degree in bioinformatics
somebody will say you know high school
somebody will say yes right just because
they are answering a different question
so as a result they have this collection
of unstructured data which are just
texts and my objective to try to
interpret that will be to categorize
them assign them to different groups and
measure the number of responses per
group so that makes it interpretable
right when i look at this chart i can
quickly understand what this exchange
really boils down to
and that is the challenge in structuring
data that also comes from biology or
biomedical research what kinds of data
do we have in biology and biomedical
research that need to be structured we
have imaging
streaming data for example video
different types of omics data
chemical interactions
clinical records and different types of
phenotypic
data for example cell morphology so all
of these
have to be converted to a series of data
frames and the objective of preparing
the data for analysis is really knowing
how in each one of these these are very
different types of data imaging
video data genomic data right they're
very different when we obtain them
how to process them in such a way that
we can end up with a data frame that
aligns the different samples or pieces
of information
and gives them features and so this is
what we're going to be working with
today
today we're going to be looking at omix
data so when we say omix what do we
really mean by that there are many
different types of omics data and what
makes them omics data is that they are
generated by high throughput automated
technologies like sequencing and they
could really be used to explore
different types of biological processes
in molecular and cell biology we
typically look at
how the phenotype for example cell
morphology or function
is defined by the code of the dna
and the transcription of that code
into proteins and so
we will look at sequencing the dna for
example nucleotides in the dna
epigenomic regulation
how we can
you know detect dna methylation patterns
or chromatin
packing
signals
and see the transcription of that code
into functional proteins
so
the challenge to create a structured
data set is to really take that
sequencing data
different types of sequencing data or
different types of omics data and
make them into a structured format which
is going to be a data frame and so what
we'll do today is we'll take a few
examples of such pipelines that process
data
from their raw format the way that they
come out of a sequencer for example and
structuring them into a table
once the table exists or many tables
exist now we can perform
statistical analysis and really
identify important trends for biomedical
or biological questions
what kinds of questions
well here we have a few examples right
this is kind of translational biomedical
research typically you're going to be
asking the question
about patients how are these patients
grouped
how are they different by response to
different treatments how can i
categorize or stratify diseases
sometimes these questions are population
health sometimes they are personalized
individual
disease progression foreign individual
patients
sometimes we want to take it further and
we want to say well based on our
understanding of data how do i intervene
are there specific targets are there
specific
interactions between drugs are there
specific diagnostic conclusions based on
these tabs a bit right so these are the
types of questions that we're going to
be asking today we're going to look at
some of these examples so that we
understand machine learning in the
context of answering questions with data
onyx logic as a whole the resource and
the reason why sonarika asked you all to
sign up at the beginning of the session
is because we're going to be leveraging
some of the methods that are described
in detail on the portal and you will
have access to analytical tools that you
can try to run such analyses and get
from raw data to structured to that
interpretable
and the onyx logic portal is a complete
roadmap for data science and application
to biomedical research data where you
will find different data sets you will
be able to explore and visualize them
and understand those methods
and hopefully get enough insights and
understanding about these topics so that
you can then apply them to
a research project of your own and that
is really the idea behind all mixed
logic and the reason why we're doing a
lot of these webinars and workshops is
to introduce you to the resources so
that you can start learning on your own
in the portal you will find detailed
explanations about every single type of
phonics data that you are typically
going to be working with
including multinomics integration so the
process of exploring these different
types of regulation
leads us to the need of integrating
these different types of signals
together and machine learning is
oftentimes used for multi-omics
integration as well and so that is why
we're going to talk about several
different examples like genomic data
transcriptomic data and metagenomic data
so that we can understand the
relationships between these biological
phenomena and how machine learning plays
a role in each one of those
in terms of applications you can start
thinking about how these are applied in
ecology infectious diseases neuroscience
and biotechnology and on the portal you
will find project examples coming from
all of these domains where you can
practice some of these methods and see
how they are used by people that are
experts in the field that have published
and that have produced important
insights using such data what kinds of
projects are these
some of these projects are diagnostic
type projects so for example how do you
identify patterns associated with a
specific disease
sometimes we take a look at complex
single cell data and we try to extract
meaning from
different types of tissue composition
that are typically composed of different
types of cells
or we can find associations or
relationships for example association
between microbiome composition and
infection
today however we will use two specific
examples and these are going to be two
data sets
so if you could already paste the links
uh in chat to uh these specific uh
projects
um
these projects are modeling cancer
precision medicine which is a collection
of cell lines that represent different
subtypes of breast cancer
and an example from tcga the cancer
genome atlas where we will find
data on liver cancer
but in addition to this on the portal
you will be able to find many different
examples including examples from papers
thank you and so in the chat you will
find a link and that link is the tcga
liver cancer precision oncology
okay
so
how
do we use
analytical methods to extract insights
from data sets like these
the typical
flow of information
you know for someone who is doing stitch
research is to have
data
that is cleaned and prepared
explored in the red right here in the
middle
and then
ready to ask specific questions or
testing your hypothesis and so as we
look at these different types of project
examples or data examples
we should be also thinking
why were these data generated right what
was the reason why these data was
generated and we will find that both of
these examples do not follow the
standard process from experimental
design where an experimentalist came up
with a hypothesis
and said to test this hypothesis
i want to now analyze i want to now
create data right to test this
hypothesis both of these examples were
generated without a hypothesis
they were just a collection of different
types of cell lines or just patients
that all fell into this great category
or general category of cancer patients
and so because this is the nature of
data sets
we have to rely on exploring the data
sets first or mining these data sets
first to come up with a hypothesis come
up with a question and once we find this
question now we can turn to
different types of models that will help
us get inference and inference really
means that i can find some pattern and i
can find the application of this pattern
to the greater population
and in the context of that
a lot of people start turning to machine
learning
for a very specific reason most of these
data sets do not have a control
versus a condition they have many
conditions they have many phenotypic
categories and to be able to ask
questions about many categories we have
to turn or it we will benefit from
turning to using machine learning
because it really provides us with that
flexibility and with greater sensitivity
and because of that
the use of machine learning and biology
has been growing exponentially
so here is a chart from a publication
the publication is called
recommendations for machine learning
validation biology and basically this
paper talks about how
the benefits of machine learning the
sensitivity of machine learning and the
ability to use machine learning easily
has led to adoption of machine learning
across the specter of biological
biological research and biomedical
research
and the problem that they have
identified is that this exponential
growth in use of
machine learning also comes with a
negative effect and that is a growing
number of papers that actually don't
apply in the evaluation of their results
because
in many cases you have two major
categories of users and those are
biologists that now use machine learning
to identify signal
or computer scientists that really don't
have the biological background they use
these tools because they understand the
value of these tools
but in many cases unfortunately that
leads to this gap of no validation and
no independent test sets to kind of
validate the findings and a lot of times
no biological validation either
so as a result of that the downside of
machine learning is that it's so easy to
use it is so
meaningful in many cases
you have to understand the methods
really clearly and you have to
understand the settings of these methods
and then you have to understand how to
validate your findings and that is going
to be a critical portion of today's and
future workshops for us to not only know
about machine learning but also know how
to use it properly
and
with that you know there are also many
many different methods from
unsupervised to supervised to
semi-supervised
to deep learning and so when we look at
these methods we're going to be able to
compare and contrast those methods we'll
be able to understand the benefits and
the limitations of each one of those
methods and hopefully we will also be
able to understand how to extract from
these methods reliable insights that we
can interpret and we can use in our
research
and that's not always simple because in
many cases the biological principles of
for example control versus condition
don't always apply to the data sets that
we're going to be using and so here is
an example gene expression profiles
in a particular data set that has
multiple groups that cluster together
don't always
follow this expectation of differential
genomics branch right and these kinds of
problems are going to be common across
the spectrum of data sets that we're
going to be using in a session like
today where we will look at different
types of bioinformatics pipelines we'll
look at how to incorporate them so that
we can get structured data and then
start asking questions about
relationships between clinical and omix
data for diagnostic and therapeutic
design purposes
and
furthermore
you can actually see how once these data
sets are clear and these principles are
clear you can actually start scaling up
the application of machine learning to
a process where you automate this whole
pipeline
and you get
interesting insights about predicting a
particular uh
feature or category using such models so
we'll talk briefly about this how to
deploy a model to production at the end
of these workshops
now so nalika already introduced you to
the platform and i just want to clarify
how we're going to use these different
tools so i talked a little bit about
omixlogic the portal where you will find
the datasets you will find additional
resources to help learn about these
different types of data but i also want
to speak about the platform briefly
so
once you sign up on the omixlogic portal
you automatically get a profile on this
portal that you will be able to run
pipelines on and these pipelines are
going to be something that you will
learn
uh the logic of analysis you'll be able
to use big data so uh uh you know
practicing or kind of doing your
research
and you'll be able to apply
many different types of analysis quickly
so that you are not hindered by the
technical complexities of each one of
these types of data
in addition there's a section called
data mining where you will find
different methods of supervising and
supervised analysis that we will be able
to try in today's session and then
download the results as
the result of the output of the pipeline
as well as scripts that run these
analyses and explore them
now in the pipelines you will find this
logic uh following a
color-coded explanation so in each
pop-up you will find an explanation
about the specific methods that you've
used and those explanations are also
going to be consistent across many
different types of methods
in addition to this as i mentioned once
you run a pipeline you'll be able to
download the script and those scripts
could be practiced on our coding
playground so this coding playground
is going to help you practice
syntax
and introduce you to challenges and so
once you understand the syntax you'll be
able to practice on those challenges and
really understand how to write code
independently or how to at least modify
code independently
we um know that one of the most popular
languages today is python and in the
biomedical and biology community r is
also a very popular math uh scripting
language so we are going to limit
ourselves to just those two python and r
that doesn't mean that others cannot be
used but in our uh sessions we're going
to be using python and r
to for those of you that are new to
python and r you can really get started
with r and python by looking at some of
the coursework that we have available uh
just to understand the syntax understand
how these languages work
and then we
we kind of introduced the context of
data science and then go from
statistical analysis to machine learning
and so in the course twerk that kind of
follows what we're going to be doing
today
we have these parallel courses uh called
bioml and we have three of these courses
bioml the logic behind machine learning
biomel in python and biometal and r and
all of them will explore these
challenges
data wrangling
machine learning and statistics for high
throughput data unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis machine
learning for data visualization
then detailed review of methods for
clustering
methods for supervised machine learning
or classification
feature selection and signatures
and then regression and generalized
linear models and finally deep learning
so if you want to go through all of
these topics we recommend getting
started with these courses and so
briefly i will just show you
where to find these courses on the
portal
so
if you're on the portal together with me
and you kind of go back to the menu you
can click on the course tab
and type in here bio ml and so you will
find here these three courses that i
just mentioned bio ml logic
biomel python and biomelr
and
if you want to participate in these
courses anyone even with a free
registration can get started so if you
want to get started you will find inside
lessons
many of them are free so you can go in
and get started with learning about some
of these methods
and
you will find also that once you've
started the course you'll be able to go
to your profile and see that under the
courses that you have started right here
okay so with that
let me pass this on to dr raghav
who is going to be
speaking about these methods in greater
detail and introduce you to some
practical exercises where you can start
learning how to apply these methods to
the data sets that he will introduce
thank you thank you very much elia and
yeah and let me find ways to share my
screen
okay i hope
all of you can see me scream
yeah all right yeah we can yes thank you
okay
so you already had
i mean hello and welcome to everybody
for the first uh
you already had an introduction to um
how to use various uh comics data
and then process it and then convert
those unstructured data that comes
straight out of the sequencer machine to
structured data so we can use and employ
different types of data like genomics
data transcriptomics data metabolomics
data and then convert them and use a set
of organized processing steps in
sequential order that we will often
refer to as pipeline and and these
pipelines are specific to each types of
each and every type of omics data that
we can analyze and at the end of the
pipeline we are going to get or we will
convert the unstructured data into
semi-structured or structured data uh
this structured data can be employed for
um further downstream statistical
analysis
that we have uh let's yeah
so uh
a simple example of uh such a pipeline
setup is is when you use high throughput
sequencing to measure genomics data we
generally generate a short reads of
sequences from randomly selected random
fragments of dna or rna these fragments
at first have to be aligned to the
reference genome so once these fragments
are aligned and
the reads can be analyzed for matches or
mismatches to the reference sequences
these matches and mismatches uh can be
um and then uh tabulated and transferred
into a
set of um
structured data often um these this
structured data as uh will be uh used in
um in the context like comparing uh
mutations between
in ontology comparing mutations between
cancerous cells tumor cells and normal
cells to understand how these mutations
might affect important genes that are
involved in tumor growth or in disease
progression or in developing resistance
to
certain therapeutic
conditions so to analyze such data we
can
prepare a table of uh muta mutability
index or somatic scores for each genome
position and that is going to ah that
that will be our structured data that is
coming um that
results from the genomics data analysis
yeah furthermore
you can also
compile these um
these data into a much smaller file
called variance calling file or vcf
file format and this file can either be
visualized
by annotating the genes and visualizing
the mutations or this can further be
sorry yes okay is it
can you see my screen
wait let me stop and share again thank
you
yes can you see it now i think it's is
it moving okay
yes it is okay perfect
so yeah um
so how to how to get or how to create
this structured file for genomics
analysis you can take the raw first q
files and uh use the talbot bioinfo
platform to set up a an example a
pipeline or set up a pipeline that is
going to uh convert these fast q files
into a table of vcf files structured
data that we can employ for
visualization or further downstream
analysis
let's uh go to uh
let's cut cut here and go to a demo
pipeline or set up a demo pipeline in
the talbot bioinfo platform so that we
can get a taste of how to
set up a genomics uh pipeline or
genomics data
yeah pipeline in there it's stopped by
info platform and those who have um
credentials please log into server t bio
info
and when you log in you are going to
get a screen like this
and in this screen
please follow along as
as you have and if you are
if you have any
hiccups or if you feel any
necessity to
ask me to wait or proceed we can do that
and have an interactive session so
please
log in to server t bioinfo platform and
under
mutation variant and parallel analysis
of mutation variant data so you
generally have uh
we generally have the collection of
different pipelines are setting up
different pipelines and algorithms for
different types of analysis as elia had
explained it to you so for several of
these analysis we have prepared
what we call as demo pipeline where
users you can get a
get an experience of setting up an
analysis pipeline and uh
and understand how each and every step
that is involved in setting up this
pipeline is is being
incorporated into this analysis in the
into the platform and you also get um
access to the
processed or structured data at the end
of setting up this demo pipeline which
you can download and perform your
analysis uh downstream analysis or
practice your analysis that you have
been uh learning in the leunomics
platform so let's let's go here in the
mutation variant analysis and the
mutation within data
section
please click this
down arrow and then you have several
demo pipeline that has been
carefully constructed or carefully
designed for you so let's check one of
those
so you are going to get
experience of setting up setting up a
pipeline from various several different
options to so uh in the demo pipeline
and also in when you are going to set up
your own pipeline um you get a
you get suggestions for
your next possible steps that you can do
or that you can perform within the
available
data depending upon what you have
selected for the previous step so since
this is a demo pipeline the necessary
files have already been uploaded and
they have been referenced so we started
and we start
and say okay and before selecting each
and every option you will get a
short
information window of what that is going
to what that algorithm is going to
perform for example this algorithm is
going to clean up your pcr uh
amplification
duplicates and amplification biases
and you click ok and then you have
several of these uh
from several of these options now we
have only one option available for our
next logical step and um
yes omnia please
you can share it in the chat chat box
also
i think you're still muted
that's okay so yeah so to go forward
let's click
next step in the pipeline where we are
going to after cleaning up the pcr
amplification artifacts we are going to
map these sequences i'll map these
shortlies onto the reference genome and
then we click ok and then our next
possible output is
our next possible
option for this pipeline or for this
setup is going is highlighted
as a
variant differential variant calling
algorithm
so you click ok
and then you use somatic sniper
to compare the
variants that are calculated from two
different
biological types then you end the
pipeline here
so once you end the pipeline
you get access to uh
yeah iman though in the same demo you
have more options
i have more options than your screen
when you click some of those options and
if you do uh if you follow
either of those options you are going to
get access to a different demo pipeline
one of them is going to be
a visualization pipeline the other is
going to give you output like uh yeah
like this a tabular output like uh
pipeline so uh depending upon what you
have clicked so far you will get uh
different uh options and you'll get yeah
you you just try to click through uh
through them and understand what is uh
um
understand what yeah what is being
analyzed through the output
files is there a link of recording in
this uh demo
um
yes there are yeah there are uh
recordings that talks about these demo
pipeline and this uh
sonalica will share with you uh where to
find those recordings and uh
for the purpose of today's session let's
move forward so this is this is how you
can perform a genomics analysis and then
download the variant calling file since
this file is too big for uh current and
for current session to complete download
let's move on
to to the powerpoint presentation
okay can you see the screen
i think yes so uh a similar omix data
another example for anomic data is
transcriptomics data so such data
transcriptomics data represents the mrna
expression which is one of the very good
way to analyze what is actually going on
inside the cell by observing active
transcription of protein coding genes
and
when
when we normally know that dna is first
transcript to rna and then rna is
translated to protein and depending upon
the conditions and the specific
conditions of the cell and the stress
that cell is undergoing these expression
of the protein will change and will be
characteristics to the phenotypical
condition of the cell or the sample that
we are analyzing
so uh
to uh to compare between genomics and
transcriptomics analysis uh
transcriptomics analysis is simply not a
subset of genomics analysis by leaving
out non-coding part uh protein coding
regions generally in in in the dna or
the genome contain large stretches of
non coding sequences called introns and
when these introns are spliced out
in rna transcripts then we will have a
different
splice forms for the same
gene being encoded or the same gene
being developed and depending upon the
condition depending upon the phenotype
of the cell some of these
splice forms will be expressed more
often than the other and this such an
analysis is going to help us understand
the state or help us understand the
biological condition of the cell or
will be extremely useful in
performing a differential gene
expression analysis which is just going
to compare the expression levels of
cells
for example of
tumor cells and normal cells
so um how to set up such a pipeline we
can again go to the demo pipeline in uh
in the turbo bioinfo platform and we
will now for this analysis we will
download the data and see what is the
output data what does the output data
look like so um i will come back to the
setting up of this pipeline in in a bit
and
when you set up a transcriptomics
analysis pipeline as a result you will
obtain um a table of continuous numeric
data that is annotated by
gene id
and organized by samples in a given
experiment so your columns are going to
be different sample names and your rows
are going to be different gene ids given
in the form of ensembl ids are given in
the form of transcriptions so the
intersection will actually tell you
uh the expression level for that
particular gene id and in that
particular
transcript in that particular sample
so let's again go back to uh server
bioinfo server
and
set up a
pipeline for
transcriptomic data analysis this time
we are going to download the data to
check or to
get a feel for how the transcriptomics
structure data looks like and what we
can do from that or what we can learn
from this data
so when you uh
go to server
server dot t bio info and um
under the transcriptomics section uh you
can click this
down arrow and then click either of
these projects to
to set up a demo pipeline let's click
the cell line project
and here also the input files necessary
fast queue files our input files are
already been inputted and
and
the pipeline is already run and
completed and for the educational
purposes we have developed this demo
pipeline so that you can get a feeling
for setting up this
transcriptomics analysis to know more
about different options or different
algorithms that are involved in these
different options of preprocessing
mapping onto genome or mapping on to
transcriptome and quantification of
these expression levels and differential
expression analysis and
other annotation analysis so you can
refer to that transcriptomics extensive
transcriptomics course or program ah
from where you can learn lot of
information yeah
yeah a lot of information regarding the
choice of the algorithm and how to uh
use certain algorithms for certain data
sets that we have so let's start this
process again this is going to tell you
um a very basic outline of how this
rna-seq analysis is going to be
performed so it involves pre-processing
mapping and quantification of expression
level at its basic
level yes omnia i think you have erased
your hand please
share your questions in the chat i'm
following the chat window all along so
after this you uh perform trimomatic
which is going to
clean or which is going to
trim out the
technical and adapter sequences that are
necessary for
identifying our samples in the pool of
samples that has been sequenced together
so let's click okay and rush through a
little bit uh
do pcr cleaning
and then we have an option uh now to for
example mapping on to genome or mapping
on to transcriptome transfer so we will
uh now
select mapping on to transcript home
option but you can also very well select
highsatch 2 which is going to map onto
uh genome process
so about i2 will map the reads onto the
transcriptome
and after this we get an uh get an
option or we get a highlight for
selecting the um
selecting the expect
expression uh
quantification table from arsenal
so this is going to uh use expectation
maximization algorithm to
count uh or to uh calculate or quantify
the expression levels of different genes
and then giving give give it to us in a
um
in a tabular format so let's click ok
and then we end this pipeline
and click ok
and
you get
yes
you get option to download demo pipeline
so from here you'll get several
different options for example uh you
will get um
expression levels of all iso forms in
the cell lines and expression levels of
yeah and expression levels of all the
genes in the cell line and expression
levels of exon that are specific to
exons in this in this this specific uh
sample and we also get these are all
absolute quantified quantified
expression levels and
we also get a link to
normalized and annotated expression
level so you can click these and
download these results i have already
downloaded these and
if you are if you are following along
with me uh download these um download
these results and we will open those
results up in the excel and and
take a peek through what we can do with
these uh
with these output results so let's yeah
let me open up these files in excel
so let me share everything so that is
easy for you to follow
okay so uh i have downloaded this
annotated cell line and also the
expression
of genes in the cell uh txt so let's um
quickly
import these files into excel
to see how the structured data looks
like
yeah okay
can you see my screen i think it's still
visible let me make it a little bit
bigger so that it's not very small so as
i mentioned uh yes thank you as i
mentioned in the on the column you'll
have the sample types and on the rows
you will have the ensemble ids and you
you find um
the raw counts for these exp expression
table uh all along here so if we use or
if i use uh
if i download the
annotated normalized and annotated
table
let it open you can quickly see the
difference between these two tables
for example this is as
as
as it has been mentioned this is an
annotated table so what does this
annotation mean this annotation means
simply
the files are the samples are properly
annotated you see here
the samples are annotated by their
respective names instead of just
mentioning this as
the file names or the run information
file names of the fascia files and
their values are normalized now we can
see that their values are normalized
because we do not have values like
15 000 and 16 000 anymore
everything is between something yeah
roughly between less than 10 and they're
also negative values so they are
centered and normalized so when will you
use
for example a data in a non-normalized
format and data in a normalized format
so for the
downstream analysis like statistical
analysis we can prefer to use the
normalized
data because
because most of the statistical
techniques that we are going to employ
will require some sort of or some form
of normalization at our end and even if
we don't use the normalization we have
to perform our own normalization
on it so this yeah this is um
yeah
excuse me for just two minutes and i'll
be back
oh
thank you everybody and sorry about that
uh
so let's uh
yeah
so let's let's go forward and uh for
example and see what we can do with this
structured data
from our end
[Music]
so yeah so this is uh
the normalization is going to be
at a different level depending upon what
we chose either it's going to be
count expression uh normalized count
data or it's going to be tpm or fpgame
depending upon what we use
yes
so uh let's move forward another type of
data is actually is
meta genomics or microbiome data uh
where we are uh where in this
specific data we are going to look at
samples that contain millions of
microorganisms that are
represented by genomes which are very
different from each other from these
samples to to structure such a such a
data that is completely varied and
variable and completely varied and lot
of variation involved with that
within this data
we have to organize this information
into categories and functionally relate
these genes to
or functionally relate the genes that
are common to all these organisms like
like for example ribosome from which we
can compare to a database of known
sequences and then assign these
genes that are common
to different organisms and quantify
their levels so this is what is done in
for example in uh in metagenomics
analysis so uh since there is a lot of
variability uh in in meta genomics
analysis
there is a necessary to denoise a
sequencing data and map these sequencing
data of found genes onto a database of
known
known organisms or known bacteria or
non-viral
virus as
counterparts and we can classify these
sequences into um for example closely
related
taxonomic groups that are called
operational taxonomic unit so the
sequences that are within or that form
uh that are from part of uh these
specific opu's that are as called as uh
in short their operational taxonomic
unit are perceived to be closely
are perceived to be
from closely related species as they
share some somewhere around from 96 or
97 percentage identical identity uh in
their sequence at their sequence level
so uh
so what do we have here we can again set
up uh some demo pipeline in uh for meta
genomics analysis and download the
amplicon data using data to uh analysis
so uh for this uh for the
yeah for
for this i'm not going to go through the
demo uh pipeline or we can actually go
through the demo pipeline we we still
have some more time let's see yes okay
um
let's
perform this demo pipeline and and i
will show you how to get the data and
what we can do with this data
so uh where can you access the
metagenomics demo pipeline again if you
go to the server t bio info uh platform
uh
down here under the metagenomics section
under amplicon uh analysis then you can
set up metagenomics demo amplicon
analysis for um
for the data that
that involves serving up or that
involves
understanding the microbiome population
of a mouse that is fed with high fat
diet and that is fed with normal diet so
you start
and
[Music]
use a
quality control so this is going to yeah
you can read through
what this actually what each and every
step actually does and you will find
that in in specifically in meta genomics
pipeline and analysis a lot of denoising
and lot of
normalizing normalization and batch
effect correction is going on
because of the nature of the data and
the variability that it possesses
and yeah
these steps will be very important in
our next section
because where we are not just going to
click and set up pipelines for
converting these unstructured data to
structured data where we are going to
perform some of the analysis on the
structured data so that we can
understand how the what the analysis
does to our structured data uh
when we download the output files so
here when you download these output
files you can actually download the
quality profile or you can download the
filoseq plots so if you download these
plots
and save it there
i can actually open with
chrome so that you can
see this
so you will get uh so you will get
abundance calculated by different
samples and they are properly annotated
uh and you also get
a
phylogenetic tree for a different
operational taxonomic unit and that are
specific to um
that are color coded by uh different
sample uh group of samples so uh
yeah and and and and furthermore lot of
other downstream analysis results are
also provided here so we can get a
yeah we can get a um
one second yes
so we can get what we are going to look
through or what we are going to
understand from from such an analysis uh
by performing or by going through the
output file first what you are going to
understand what you are going to get is
uh we will see the abundance ratio or we
will see the
presence and abundance of different
family or different phyla of bacteria or
micro microbiome
for different samples and where these
operational taxonomic units start in
terms of their frequent similarities
with respect to each other and how their
abundance is actually
how their abundance level quantifies um
their relation so these information that
you can get so we again started from um
unstructured uh sequence uh sequencer
output data and we are arriving here
structured data which is essentially a
table a table of
continuous or categorical data so most
often than not it is a continuous
numerical data which will i genomics
analysis signifies the mutation index or
mutability index and in terms of
transcriptomics analysis it is going to
tell us
expression quantities of genes under
different sample and in terms of
meta genomics analysis it is going to
tell abundance of operational taxonomic
unit for different samples so that is uh
this
structure data is what we are going to
use for our further
uh analysis
which involves a statistical um
operation taxonomy obviously the
standard can obviously get
which family of um bacteria or which
family of uh which file or which order
of bacteria that these o2us represent so
that is going to uh give us information
about the annotation uh for different
otus so this is not the only way where
you can get structured data so you can
either get the unstructured data from
the sequencers and then follow up with a
detailed analysis pipelines and
set up detail analysis pipeline and get
the structured data or you can find
structured data that are deposited into
big data resources like uh ncbi
platforms where you will have
lots and lots of structured data
expression table data
that is submitted to
geo or gene expression omnibus where you
will have option to download the raw
sequence file where you can create your
own structured data from these from
these raw sequence file or you can
download
normalized or some sort of processed
expression table
which will be helpful if you are going
to
perform
analysis for a lot of
data sets or a large number of data sets
where we will not have uh enough time or
enough resources to
run this pipeline for large number of
data sets so there are also specific
databases and repositories
like
cancerx cancer genome atlas tcga cosmic
which are
which are specific to the
cancer or tumor
related
omics data
information and we also have array
express which is going to be
focusing on microarray data for
different um
[Music]
for different data sets and uh protein
atlas well we'll get proteome data
proteomics data and others as well so
you'll also
if you want to focus not on human system
and if you want to focus on something
like uh
infectious diseases and the pathology
pathogenesis or viruses then you'll have
specific resources for that and this is
go this these resources and associated
uh repositories became
extremely helpful in current pandemic
situation where they host lots and lots
of data related to sars and other uh
viruses and
like ebola for which uh nextgen
sequencing method or high throughput
sequencing method was extremely
successful in tracking and
developing effective combatives for um
getting through this pandemic so
i will stop here and take couple of
questions if you have next is going to
be
again an interactive session where we
are going to look what we can do with
the
structured data in terms of statistical
analysis and what we can gain from this
structured data please yeah if you have
any questions please share it in the
chat i'm following the chat along all
along
and yeah
so okay if you do not have any questions
let's uh let's go forward let's move uh
forward so
we spoke about we spoke about this where
we have a
lot of
unstructured data and
and there is a huge gap between
unstructured data and structured data so
we can effectively use these
unstructured data to perform our
analysis and
develop a lot of structured data and
find
very
impactful insights
for um for different biological
questions many of the biological
questions and many of the high impact
biological questions are actually
analysis done on or re-analysis done on
data that is already been submitted to
the repository so uh so we can also
follow the steps and then create lot of
good signs so what is a structured data
we have been talking for something like
one hour about structured data
so what is the structured data so such a
data at its simplest form is going to be
a table
and there are different ways of
referring to this table depending upon
which
programming background that you come
from and one two of the most popular
programming languages or background uh
is
r and python in both these platform it
is referred to as a data frame so uh it
is referred to as data frame and there
is a
underlying difference between
the object data frame which is a table
of collection of uh different
data types like it can be numerical data
type it can be um as a categorical data
type or it can be
binary
data type a logical data type or it can
be yeah
something called a factor data type
which is like a
restricted response to the input like
blood um
blood types and like uh eye color etc
etc so a data table as you can see here
is a table of equal number of rows and
equal number of
entries in the rows and columns
that is going to represent
the samples and the
structured data
as a collection of data of different
types
of course there are also other
structured data format like matrix
which is essentially a table of
numerical objects only numerical objects
so matrix cannot contain a table or
cannot contain a column or a row that is
of non-numeric nature so
similarly array is is another form of
structured data where you'll have
indices that are referring to elements
that can either be numeric or either be
character so uh
this
in in our context of moving forward the
one of the important thing that you want
to take
and take into account is how to
take your structure data that you have
downloaded as i have uh
demonstrated you from the pipeline or
from some any other analysis method
or from the
[Music]
repositories and load it into a platform
so that it becomes a data frame on which
we can perform our statistical analysis
so why do we need to do this why do we
need to perform the statistical analysis
so
because
any measurement for example since we are
converting measurements of omics data
into digital data so any measurement
carries information that is signal which
is of extreme interest to us and
information that is uh that arises due
to um random noise or errors which is
which is uh which could be masked or
superimposed
by the or on the signal that is of
interest depending upon their strength
so these errors are random and of course
they are unwanted but
but they are always present and they
actually
reduce or diminish the accuracy and
precision of the measured
data and this is why we have to resort
to
statistical methods and in in
generally in statistical analysis our
aim is to find a way or our aim is to
find a function or find a model that can
effectively separate the signal from the
noise
with appropriate or with account for
accounting for appropriate variation and
so in the end when we perform these
statistical analysis
we can
describe the data in
in
for example using a function or using a
mathematical model so that way we can
use this model to predict or to
generalize the
tendency or generalize the structure
that is observed a pattern that is
observed in the data to future events or
to general population so this is why we
have to uh perform some of the basic
statistical analysis and resort to
performing these statistical analysis
methods so let us
move forward what are the very
two most useful
methods
that will help us in
cleaning up the data or normalizing the
data is
normalization based on quantile
normalization and transformation of
scales through log scale so why are
these important because this data
converts
this this transformation converts for
example
some of the data which are not normal in
nature or which are not uh oh sorry you
go back i click too much too much
okay
it's not going back for me
yes
good so uh
this this is not that is not normal in
nature for example your typical gene
expression data which which can have a
lot of values that are extremely low uh
uh a lot of quantity of values that are
extremely low and very few values that
are extremely high so why is this
transformation important this
transformation is important because many
of the statistical many of the methods
or downstream analysis that we are going
to perform rely or
have some sort of underlying assumption
on the data or some of the derived
characteristics for the data that is
gaussian or that is normal in nature so
that that is why performing a
normalization
or transformation of the scale to a log
scale will help us uh even out or will
help us understand the pattern uh in a
better way so uh how it is actually
helping us um
for example for a non log transformed
comparison our comparison between any
two genes can look like this where many
of the
information is actually populated very
close to zero and very few of the
information is actually false along the
line which which can be extremely
misleading because when you convert the
scale into uh log scale we actually see
a very good uh acceptance between or
very good correlation between the
expression level of these two genes and
by performing a quantity normalization
what we actually essentially do is we
take the expression levels of different
samples and then we match their
match their medians or match their um
average expression levels so that all of
the
samples follow the same uh or similar uh
trajectory or similar distribution so
by by performing a quantity
normalization we are actually forcing
our data to be normally distributed so
that our analysis can hold ah real yeah
it can hold real meaning and value so um
in the
spectrum of a gene expression table for
example as as often we are going to
relate to gene expression table because
um
in in the following ah
slides so we have we can actually uh
separate this spectrum into three parts
where at its lowest end we have a
signal and noise
intermingled with each other and it's
going to be extremely difficult to
separate or identify which is signal
which is nice so we are not interested
in some of the data that is present here
and in the
and in the center where we will have
normal gene expression levels and this
is going to be very relevant for us
because we have to set up
expression levels or expression
quantities at the normal scale with
which we can compare the expression
levels at the highest end so this is the
significance signal which we are
extremely interested in and which will
be we will be using for comparing the um
expression levels of
samples
of different nature so for this to
happen we should not normalize this
significant level so that is why when we
are going to perform a quantized
normalization we have to mention or we
have to
use a threshold beyond which are above
which the normalization is not going to
take any or is not going to have any
effort so we will set up this pipeline
in a short while and i will tell you why
such an analysis or why such methods are
important for example these methods are
important to test our hypothesis or
to test
our interpretation or to test a
hypothesis that what we are
about the pattern that we are finding in
our data for example usually for
for such a
statistical analysis we will have
condition a versus condition b and we
will be extremely interested in
identifying what are the things that are
depending upon the structured data what
are the patterns that are found in
condition a that are
not found in condition b so by this ah
by this analysis we can actually tell
whether the condition samples in
condition a and samples in condition b
are significantly different with respect
to each other so
this is going to happen using uh yeah
for example
sorry
okay uh this can actually follow a lot
of uh
exploratory data analysis which is going
to help us learn a lot about our data so
uh
our next session next live session that
is there tomorrow is going to have a
hands-on
session or hands-on
tutorial about how to perform this
exploratory data analysis for the data
where we will explore or where we will
use
some of these techniques like using a
scatter plot or using box plots or bar
plots to
generally understand the underlying
pattern in our data and that can be
used or leveraged to
develop a hypothesis or to generate a
hypothesis that we have to test or to
generally set up a contrast or
comparison level that we can
use use for or
use for example a t-test analysis to
understand the variation between
two
groups
two sample
conditions in general so such an
analysis is going to give us for example
patterns that are specific to one sample
set with respect to the other sample set
and from this
from this we can infer or we can make a
lot of biological uh meaningful
biological implication and inference ah
why such sample or why this difference
may be biologically relevant and useful
and what are the
important or what are the significant
genes in terms of transcripts data
analysis
and their expression levels that are
specific to one set of samples and are
not in
not specific to the other set of samples
and how their expression pattern vary
whether the expression patterns of these
genes can be
employed
in
serving up are in using this as a
biomarker for these specific samples
so uh
so let's for example
take this for uh further and i will i
will pause here to ask if you have any
queries or not if you do not have any
queries then we will move on to perform
some of some unsupervised learning and
machine learning methods and understand
much more about our data in general so
the necessary the necessary to do
statistical analysis is i think it's
very clear for you
and what we are going to learn from this
statistical analysis is also clear so
until now we have been discussing about
comparing um samples like uh comparing
two sets of samples so if you have
for example let's say three different
conditions then we can obviously perform
uh two separate comparisons for the for
these three different conditions but
what happens when you have multiple
conditions and we cannot just keep on
performing all pairs of comparisons so
for those um for that for those times or
even for those um
specific analysis methods so we have to
rely on to
higher or more advanced statistical
more advanced statistical
methods like machine learning methods
where you can employ unsupervised
learning or supervised learning to
generally understand or to generally
identify patterns related to multiple
different sample types which are
multiple different
identities that are found in the sample
so i will pause here to ask for uh ask
if you have any queries or not if you do
not have any queries let's
go forward the next session is going to
be again an interactive session where
i'm going to follow you along um
with the courses that are found in omics
logic and also set up couple of pipeline
so we can understand how
in general um we can
use or we can use unsupervised learning
methods to
understand and to
identify patterns in our data
is everything clear so far
so if everything is pretty okay then
let's uh let's move forward so uh
generally uh we
as i mentioned we
machine learning can be separated into
two main categories of methods like
unsupervised machine learning that
focuses on
detecting patterns in data and the
second one is supervised machine
learning where once we have a labeled
data we can use these labeled data to
train a model or mathematical model or
algorithm
and then use this trained algorithm to
predict or classify a new data set so
so the main idea of of applying these
machine learning techniques is to
understand the relationships between the
features or between the genes in our
data and between the various assumptions
that
that follow or that define the data and
to model or mathematically model this
and to learn from this so that
we can better characterize the samples
accurately in terms of unsupervised
machine learning algorithms
or to predict any new uh
sample to be belonging to either of the
category that the learning algorithm has
chance to
learn about it so in the unsupervised
machine learning uh
algorithm so what we actually have is we
generally start with a data set
typically um
a table of elements like uh like your
structured data so for the
representation purposes let's understand
or let's believe let's
assume that this table of elements are
represented as
these shapes then we can use clustering
method for example different types of
clustering method like hierarchical
clustering k means clustering or pca
method to identify
groups based on the similarity of these
shapes or based on the structure that
you find in your structured data so such
method actually results in
separating
the data
and assigning samples to groups of
elements that are present so this
separation or this
this uh segregation of patterns usually
use or employs um
a
dimensionality reduction method which is
a transformation of
of your
variance that is found in your original
data to uh to newer dimensions or to
transform linear or non-linearly
transform dimensions which we will
learn a little bit more about in
subsequent
slides so
so it is possible to uh understand or it
is possible to generally okay go back
sorry yeah it is possible to uh
the mice power point is actually taking
long time to respond
so the result of such clustering or
unsupervised data analysis uh machine
learning algorithm will be to give us uh
patterns in the data so that we can
group our samples or group our data into
specific groups and ah correlate these
groups with the phenotypical
characteristics that we
generally associate with so one of the
most used unsupervised machine learning
algorithms say algorithm is principal
component analysis so what is pci what
is principal component analysis and how
it is used so in pca we use the
we use a simple approach of
using components or principle components
or transform components that is going to
explain the variance of our data in the
best possible way or in the best
possible dimension so for example here
is the data let's say here's the data
that is
with with extremely low variance or
with the
that we can infer because the samples
are because the
data points are clustered together or
close very close together so for example
this is a data with a higher variance
than ah compared to this data so but in
spite of this data having higher
variance the variance that is present in
this data is not explained very well by
the axes of the choice that we have the
x and y axis does not explain the
variance that we generally see in this
specific type of data so what you can
actually do is
you can actually
draw
a vector through the multi-dimensional
space that maximizes the variance of the
data and this vector is called principle
component
so this this is not going to be a
straightforward line that is going to be
represented in a 2d scatter plot but you
can visualize this in
you can visualize this in
such a such a way ah so in a
multi-dimensional space if you draw a
tensor okay if you draw a vector not a
tensor if you draw a vector that is
going to maximize the variance that you
see
in that you see are observing your
samples so that will
become or that will form your first
principle component so you can
follow this up with
with maximizing the variance in the
second dimension that is going to form
your second principle component
go there and play take this
sorry about that yeah um
so for example uh we will visualize this
by uh
changing or converting our uh scale or
converting our
axises to represents the principal
component and not the original axis that
we chose to represent this from so such
such
uh
transformation is going to yield
separation of our samples based on their
variability or based on the maximum
variability that the samples are
that that the samples are described in
our example dataset
so let's quickly cut short here and then
demonstrate a way where you can set up a
principal component analysis uh pipeline
or pca pipeline in the
in the turbo bioinfo platform
so for this if you have a
subscription to the platform then you
can
follow along with me
if not then please go through the
where is this okay
yeah
so if not please go through the demo as
i show you and then we can
use or we can
follow along after you have gained the
subscription so in
example in the uh in the bio ml course
that elia was talking about then we have
a general we have a dimensionality
reduction methods or dimensional
deduction uh uh
method lesson so the lesson is
structured in such a way that first we
will learn about the basics or first we
will learn about the background of what
is a dimensionality reduction method and
how that is going to help us visualize
the data or how it is going to help us
and overcome what is generally
referred to as a curse of dimensionality
which is nothing but let's uh yeah let's
open up
the data
access to the data can also be a had or
can also be taken from these
these links let me share this link to
you in the chat window
if you have
access to the uh learn or mix logic then
sign in to the omixlogic and then if you
click this lesson and you can access
this lesson if not then it's going to go
to the homepage so don't uh don't think
there is something wrong with the data
or something wrong with the link
you can do this okay so um
if you log in then this lesson can you
can access this lesson so you can take
uh
these three data sets so these three
data sets are actually
aptly labeled as
input for pca with the id or input for
pc without labels and with labels etc
etc so they actually tell you or give a
given
given explanation about
how they are describing
excuse me
just a second
sorry about that just minding my kid so
um
so let's start with one of this data set
and then perform a pca analysis let's
see uh for this
for this specific lesson i think they
start with uh
they start with the input file that is
not labeled or that is not let's see uh
what is what do they mean by not labeled
so let me share everything so that you
can see what i see
so i have downloaded these three data
files and these three data files we can
visualize these files as
this one's okay uh
let's see if we can visualize it here
it's easy to visualize it here yes but
let's use excel
one second
yeah so uh first let's let's start with
the file that is mentioned as uh
expression tables without or without
label so if you
open up this file um we'll wait for the
file to uh load up yes so it is go it is
going to be your
normal
data you have uh this file this file and
we have we had our introduction to this
specific file where we had the samples
as a columns and you have your um
ensemble ids as rows so if you go to
turbo bio info platform so in the
platform you can set up a principal
component analysis
using different ways
we can either use unsupervised analysis
section or you can use utility set
utilities section or either of these so
when you use unsupervised analysis
section you use a file upload and then
you upload this file
a specific file
we upload the file without labels
the one that we just had a look
and it will yeah after uploading
let's go down and we have to
start setting up a principal component
analysis visualization or pipeline so
there are different ways of
two different algorithms that will
perform the same principle component
analysis
and
pca this option is going to give you
results without visualization and this
option is going to give you result with
a visualization to pdf format so uh
let's continue and if you start
um
if you are with me then follow along
with me let me give you a link for the
input file
where is the lesson
so the link for the input file is in
this lesson
where you can download this file and
so uh without the ids or it's going to
be here
let me copy this link address and i will
share it with you in chat
you can download this and then set up a
pipeline along with me
so um
so our pipeline is here
sorry here yeah
so once it is uploaded then you start it
and
where is the ok button
i think it's
masked by the zoo
okay it's not there
let me reset it and do it one more time
so essentially
yeah if it is taking too long
i think many of us are accessing this
turbo info platform at the same time
so what i wanted to tell is if you use
the data without label or without any
annotation and the data that has only a
sample information on the first row so
we are going to uh set up a pca pipeline
just like this where we can
start with
uploading the data from the unsupervised
analysis section and then
use pcir library and then finish it it's
a very simple
very simple pipeline and you are going
to
employ or you're going to be asked for
the option of a
number of principal components to be
calculated and if you want to scale your
data or if you don't want to scale your
data if you want to center your data or
not or and if you want to transpose your
data so transpose your data would
generally mean so in our data you see
we have
okay that is
here is our data again
so in our data we generally have samples
along the
columns and gene expression
ensemble ids along genes along the rows
but we are in
interested in understanding the patterns
between the samples
not between the genes so we have to
transform this file to perform a pca
analysis in r so that is what it is
asking so that option we have to
mention so uh yes we want to transform
this and then save up the parameters and
then download use this to run the
pipeline so this is going to give you a
pdf output of the um
of the pcr principal component analysis
that we have performed so this is the
pdf output okay let's
let me ask you what do you infer from
this
file from this output
so let's take a bit down
zoom out
so what do you eat
this output anybody
pc1 explains 15.13
of the total variability then pc to 12
percent okay
perfect so the top uh so the first
principal component is going to explain
you 15 percentage of the variance that
you uh observe in your input data and
the second principle component explains
you something around twelve percentage
so when you add up pc one and two it's
going to cover something around uh yeah
27 percentage which is not excellent but
uh we can take it uh depending upon the
say um looking at the segregation of the
data that we have but can anybody
explain or can can anybody stretch even
further to interpret this file
what do we have here do you see any
pattern and whether the pattern is
actually reflected in the colors or not
so generally not because the colors are
everywhere and if you see the colors are
the dots are actually colored by each
and every different sample so that is
not a good grouping uh method or that is
not a way in which we are going to uh
which is going to be extremely
informative yes of course you can see uh
by relating to the dark i mean colors
that are like
blue and pink which are obviously in
this area so these samples are going to
be in one
in one cluster or very close to one
cluster and these samples are going to
be in another cluster that is far away
from this but generally this is not good
because the data is not annotated so by
annotation i mean the data is not
reflecting any phenotypical
characteristics that is associated
associated with the
samples so that is what we will see
in the file uh
in the file that has the labels and that
has a groups
associated with them so the file that
has the groups are
there is only one difference between the
file that has the
or the
table that has a group on the table that
does not have the group
that difference is
how how can i make this bigger
okay
so that difference essentially is uh
there is another row uh right below the
samples uh uh right below the sample row
which tell uh which tells actually which
groups these samples by their
phenotypical type for example this is
this is non-malignant or these are the
control samples and these are the basal
type samples and these are the luminal
cancer types and
this is this is chlorine low and uh et
cetera et cetera as such the power of
such
analysis or sorry the power of such
annotation
you can actually check or you can
actually visualize in when you run this
platform with this specific output
you will see
let me show that yeah
i should have my presentation again
it's here
yeah you will actually see at the end of
the analysis you will
you can have okay let's go to the next
slide and come back to this slide
yes you will see the samples they are
they will be colored by the groups or by
the annotation that we have chosen for
or that we have opted for that becomes
extremely important because
then we can relate to the sample
segregation on the pca to the uh with
the phenotypical characteristics of the
sample so can can anybody interpret this
principle component analysis output for
me
so what do you see here and i hope you
can read the key uh labels that are down
here below here so can you please tell
me
can anybody tell me so i will explain
this
or expand the acronyms so l a sorry lihc
would are the liver carcinoma and
liver cancer
and
brca is a breast cancer and there is a
control and there is ah adjacent normal
under tumor samples among them yes dr
emman tells there is a clear
discrimination between the groups yes
there is a clear discrimination between
the groups obviously because
the colors occupy different quadrant
that we can see and
i can yeah maybe some more can be
extracted from
from this
c analysis what what is the
what do you see
if you relate to samples regret the
samples with their annotation
so the first striking feature that i see
is principle component one explains the
maximum separation or maximum variation
as as observed explains the maximum
separation between the samples and the
samples are separated by their tumor
types
so see this green and blue are liver
cancer cells
and red and orange are breast cancer
tubes breast tubes so yes so they are
separated by the tumor types first
that's a prominent separation and that's
a maximum variation that we observe in
our
input data set and the principle
component 2 is
very useful in
separating
the subsequent tumors cells or tumor
types into adjacent normal and tumor
samples so these are the
these are the um yeah
important implications are
or phenotypical associations that you
can relate to the
principal component analysis if you use
annotation by grouping method so um uh
let's
uh go back one slide so uh
not yes
sylvia yes good association yes so what
can you learn from this principle
component analysis output
so apart from the obvious things like
principal component 1 tells yeah it is
approximately or almost 22 percentage
associated and principal component two
tells almost eight percent what is uh
what is yeah what can you also find from
this analysis or from this output file
anybody i'm expecting some more
answers
please please go ahead please go ahead
it does not matter whatever yeah
whatever the output is u dots are more
correlated while orange dots
show much more variance and that is why
they are more spreaded
yeah yeah that is that is yeah that is
terrific that is excellent observation
so the blue dots are the er
samples that are annotated as er samples
have ah
very
or a very low degree of variability
among them and their triple negative
samples are very high degree of uh
variability among them as
as
characterized by this spread along the
principle component one and there is one
glaring
observation that anybody can make what
is that
yes who is that iman dr riman yes there
is one very far outlier so we have one
outlier very far out layer here and we
have generally a decent separation
between
between the sample types uh along the
principle component one and very one
very um
[Music]
obvious outlier so principal component
analysis
is not only
an unsupervised machine learning
technique or unsupervised uh analysis it
it is also employed
it is also employed as
as a part of exploratory analysis for
this specific reason one to identify
patterns and
underlying
segregation of samples and patterns of
samples and to to identify the presence
of outliers in the data so uh if we see
such outliers which
for most of the data you will obviously
see and for the other plots you are not
seeing such outliers because those data
sets are curated for the purpose of
understanding the uh
logic behind the algorithm so um yeah
just a moment
so that those are the use those are the
ways in which principle component
analysis can be used so uh let's move
ahead and see what we can
learn from uh this one
so uh
principle component analysis is just one
such method to reduce the dimensions of
your
data of your structured data so why do i
call reduce the dimensions of the
structured data because remember in the
expression table the one thing that i
never talked about is the size of those
structured data size of the
expression table and we why i have not
spoken about that because those we will
discuss in detail uh about the size and
about how to check
different statistical summary of the
data in
on
on thursday but
when you generally see
an expression table and that
is going to give something around 21 000
or 20 000
we can in theory populate 24 000
genes with their expression patterns but
you are anywhere good to see
in terms of tens of thousands
of
rows so
so
you have essentially tens of tens and
thousands of dimension to describe the
samples and their variance and their
differences and their yeah and their
patterns so you cannot obviously
visualize or you cannot make a plot that
is going to
cake or that is going to take into
account of one two three and four five
or the tens and thousands of different
uh
dimensions so when you perform a
principal component analysis or um an
analysis like that so what is what
principal component analysis does is by
um
by generating uh components that is
going to describe your data in the
in the order of most variants explained
you are essentially
reducing the number of
dimensions that is required to explain
maximal variance that you observe in
your dataset so
very soon your data is going to have
or get your data is going to cover
most of the
expression or most of the variance
explained by principle component
analysis by
through something like 10 12 or even 15
the principal component analysis is
sufficient to explain 90 percentage or
over 90 percentage of the day or the
variance that you observe in the data so
that is why they are regarded as these
linear and non-linear transformation of
dimensions are regarded as
dimensionality reduction techniques and
principle component analysis is one of
the extremely useful dimensionality
reduction techniques because
it uses the explained variance to show
or to accurately represent our data but
sometimes or most of the times this this
way of using the explained variance to
transform our dimensions into uh
into principal components might not
always work well for our kind of data
for example you remember we spoke about
meta genomic sequence data being
extremely variable and has high degree
of variance and
one another characteristics of metal
genomic sequencing data is the presence
of lot of null values so these are these
are the
different challenges that you will
encounter in your
statistical analysis steps so when you
have a data so when you are going to
analyze a data that is not populated
with a lot of null values so you can
generally use principal component
analysis to describe or to
to transform or to reduce the dimensions
but the moment that you have a lot of
null values a lot of values zero values
then
unfortunately uh you cannot use our
principal component analysis is not
going to be accurate enough for your
for the data transformation so in such
uh
conditions you can use
multi-dimensional scaling or nmds or um
principle coordinate analysis or
t-sne methods or
teeth distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding so these methods are going to
actually are going to understand the
samples based on their variability and
based on their uh
based on their relatedness so uh or
based on the neighborhoods that they can
establish in the data so these methods
can actually help us visualize the
patterns in for example in extremely
variable data and
data with lot of null values in like
meta genomics data
single cell rna
data
so
sorry sorry sorry about that yeah i will
be there so
in that instance we are going to use
something like t-sne and nmds2
to display or to
describe how connected or how
closely related different samples in our
data set are so most useful uh
usefulness of these these
non-linear
transformation dimensional reduction
methods like nmds principle coordinator
analysis and t-sne are for meta genomics
data and for single cell rna uh single
cell rna sequence
this rna-seq data so uh so those are
those are for
statistical analysis regarding principle
components using principle component
analysis so if you have any queries so
far please
please let me know
if you do not have any queries let me
yeah stop sharing and start sharing my
screen with the
showboat bioinfo platform and see what
we
what we can learn from the principal
component analysis that we can use
that we can employ in
in the
environment are in the programming
environment are okay
okay t-sne and nmds again please for
example
[Music]
so let's put it this way uh the main
goal of
multi-dimensional scaling or nmds is to
use or is to study the information and
collapse this information from multiple
dimensions into just a few so they can
be
for example they can be visualized or
they can be compared so um
principal component analysis uses
variance that is studied in the
dimensions to segregate or separate
those patterns in the samples but
methods like nmds and t-sne actually use
the distances or
primarily the euclidean distances
between the samples to
cluster them in the
in the non-linear dimensional space so
that is why you will see uh the distance
based methods like nmds and t-sne are
much more
flexible to uh accommodate outliers than
you saw with the principal component
analysis where that one big outlier was
just sitting there like a sort of so
yeah
but in the event of for example t-sne
and the nmds method you can see that
nmds is very closely
it
it resembles close to principle
component analysis but they are
coordinates analysis uh
and that uses for example
rank orders and these rank orders are
they depend upon
euclidean distances for example they
calculate the distances for
all pairs of samples and use these
distances to rank these samples with
respect to each other and then they
perform clustering on those samples so
that is how principle coordinate
analysis or nmds is going to
give us ordination or give us a sample
segregation
but while a t-sne is actually it uses uh
something like um
nearest neighbor or it uses a
connectivity uh based
method to
[Music]
establish patterns in the data and this
connectivity based method actually
depends on some of the initial steps so
whenever we are going to discuss disney
we will be discussing perplexity so
perplexity is like um
how to put it i mean yeah
if you want to have uh yeah i think
perplexity is is
is closely related to
whether you want to have microscopic or
macroscopic pattern or whether you want
to observe microscopic or microscopic
pattern or global or local pattern let's
put it this way global or local pattern
in your data so higher i think higher
perplexity is going to give you lot of
local patterns and the lower temperature
is going to give you a lot of
global i mean
pattern global pattern i am not very
sure about that but one is going to give
you global the other is going to give
you local if anybody has more
information on which one is which they
can correct me um but what it actually
does is
it
starts by assuming all the samples are
connected with all the samples and then
it it calculates the uh
neighborhoodness or nearest
neighborhoodness connectivity for these
samples and then it um
keeps on kicking out
neighbors based on their
yeah based on the
number of connections each and every
neighbor has and
thus we have or we get
not a very uniform pattern or cluster of
samples but this disney is actually
capable of
producing or capable of identifying
clusters in even in a very complex
form of data as you can see here that is
why disney has been used to study
patterns within different cell types
in single cell rna analysis and other
analysis stuff patterns
so that is yeah that is little bit more
about pc but today is not about disney
and nba so that's why i have not
prepared a lot of other slides for
disney and nmds also um
let's see if we can address it in a
thursday session or not so uh let's
quickly uh stop sharing and go to talbot
by info platform where i want to
demonstrate you
how we can employ
pc analysis or where you will find
information on pci analysis
uh to be performed using uh our as a
programming language or as a programming
environment
okay there is a new chat
okay so um
so in uh for example we saw how pca can
be set up using uh
using turbo bioinfo platforms uh
unsupervised machine learning
algorithm option where you saw um
parameters like these important
parameters now if you are going to use
uh r uh as a tool or you can also use
python as a tool we can obviously uh we
have we have a lesson that is going to
first take you through
what is principle component analysis and
the necessity to do
such
such an analysis
for the data that we have which we have
covered in xslf so it is the code based
lessons are structured in such a way
that you are first given an introduction
about what you are going to learn and
the background for the analysis to be
performed and then you are going to
learn the code in a step by step format
where you will have couple of
videos demonstrating the power of such
analysis and methods and you will have a
section where the code is broken down
into line by line
where we are explaining you the syntax
behind the code and
the necessary um options that that are
associated with each and every syntax
the goal for today's
session was to go through each and every
line but i think it's taking a long time
so i urge each and every one of you to
go through this
this code you can
this code lesson let me copy it and give
it to you it's in uh
everyone anything
so
if you are signed up into signed into uh
uh into learnomics then you can access
this lesson so uh you go through uh
the necessary libraries and packages to
be loaded and then you these are the
syntax that you have to uh deal with and
how you are going to
for example
read or how you are going to read the
table data table the structured data
that is sitting in your computer as a
text file and how you are going to load
that table into a programming
environment that is where the first step
we start with that is where the
challenge lies and
once we have the table loaded and placed
into an object that is usually a data
frame then we can perform a lot of
calculations on that and
related calculation that we want to
perform is principal component analysis
and principal component analysis
requires the data to be in a matrix
format and not in
not in data frame format if you
well let me share everything i think i
don't have uh
let me share everything so that you can
see my screen and see what i can see
so uh if you remember our
if you remember our
structured data table
usually they are without groups or they
are without labels
and
what we have is a uh is a typical
structured data with the first column as
a gene
gene ids or ensembl ids so um this is
this data this is a this is this can be
loaded into uh ours environment or
python symbol but as a data frame but um
the principal component analysis
requires uh not a data frame but a
matrix so to convert this table or this
data frame into a matrix we have to
first leave our why this one is coming
again again yeah we have to first
take this out or
use only numerical values that are in
our data frame and leave out the
ensemble ids or the
gene ids that are associated with
but don't just delete it we save it into
a different format so and then we can
convert
our data table into matrix format which
is absolutely necessary for performing
principal component analysis as we have
spoken in detail about performing
principle component analysis for
understanding the variability across the
gene across the gene expression pattern
we have to transpose our data
into
yeah transpose our data so that
for performing principle component
analysis the genes are along the
columns and the samples are all of the
rows so we do this transformation and
then we simply use the pr comp um
function to calculate the principal
component analysis so the principal
component analysis that is calculated
can be used to used to visualize using
multiple different options so
all of
these stand all of these options that
you can use to
visualize and to
color code and to
[Music]
understand the patterns in the data you
will not have such a flexibility if you
are going to employ uh automated
analysis like talbot by info platform
but why did we insist on doing this
analysis on the platform where you will
get an idea of how your data is going to
get transformed from a multi-time or a
very high dimensional structure data
into a dimensionally dimensionally
reduced uh principal components a file
uh where you will have we can use a
prince pc1 and pc2 to
perform a scatter plot and um understand
the patterns
so uh
so obviously when you plot scatter plot
it's going to have it's going to come up
like this then we can use the colors to
represent which samples are from which
groups and that annotation is is
possible and i urge all of you to go
through this
code one by one
you can have
you can understand how
the principle component can be
extremely effective in understanding the
patterns in your data not only about the
samples but also about the um
about the genes that best explains the
different yeah different segregation of
samples that can also be understood in
this loading plot and
we come down and
as it is the case with any programming
environment we don't have just only one
option to perform
any uh defined analysis method so we
we perform the principal component
analysis using pr comp library or
peercomp function but we can use the
ggplot or gg45 library to visualize the
output in a much richer uh environment
and much with lot of options and
so that you can uh yeah so that your
visualization is
easy and this is what gg45 and auto plot
is what is being used by the pca pcr
library that we have set up
that we have set up for our principal
component analysis one thing that i
forgot actually to tell you is when you
run pcr uh
library or when you run pcr uh library
option and when you finish
along with the output what you are going
to get is a zip file and that zip file
is going to uh yeah here it is vcrr
pack.zip and this zip file is going to
contain the r code that was used to
develop or that was used to generate
this output so if you are
if you understand the logic behind
performing pca by going through this
lesson you can essentially go through
that r code and then change only few of
the components to visualize or to
associate our data set with
either
either the subtypes of the tumor or with
associated risk factors which you can
see in the tcga
projects uh that yeah
that you were given linked to earlier so
we can employ this auto plot or with
gg45 or this pc our library option to
use the same calculation for pca and
then visualize that with uh
both with the subtypes of the tumor and
also with the risk factors associated
with the associated with the um data so
uh this code block is actually followed
by an extremely useful as
coda section called practice the learn
output so what you actually will find
here is you'll find small blocks of
consoles which you can use to run
which we can use to practice your codes
so at first usually the first code is
actually given
in completion so all the necessary codes
are complete where you just run and get
the output so you can open up the output
and check how
check the different visualization but
what actually follows
here is if you just type run it is not
going to run
it is going to give you okay this also
runs sorry
yes
this is you learn the code and this is
practice the output and
in this practice output you'll be given
you are given these code blocks where
you can run for different settings and
understand the output what i was
interested in telling you is the
assignment section where uh we are we
have actually
left some of the uh obvious samples some
of the obvious syntax is incomplete like
this one
and like this one so that you can uh
compare and contrast the syntaxes and
the codes that we have learned so far
from the practicing from practicing the
code and from learning the code and uh
put it up here and complete this
sentences
so that you can
run and get the satisfaction or get the
understanding of how each and every code
is going to work so now when i run this
as such it's going to give me a lot of
errors and i'm not going to get a job
complete
output so these are all very simple uh
syntax completion exercises which you
can easily finish up in less than 15 or
20 minutes if you
follow along with this course so this is
what i wanted to show you uh how
intuitive and how useful it is to go
through the r codes in the um
the analysis in the
r code environment in learnomics logics
platform so that is what you are going
to get and
you will also get
an option to go beyond the basics where
you will
find
multiple
not so straightforward and complicated
ways to generate uh much more useful
plots which you can explore uh explore
them and then practice them also and in
the end uh in when you have a python
lesson not our lesson you are given a
collab notebook which you can use to uh
change or modify the course as uh as it
suits your data or as it suits your
analysis methods so
this is the the going through the
sections of learning the code and
practicing the code is very very useful
because uh along the way you will set
exactly the same parameters that you
used to set in the um
in the pipeline analysis so that is
going to be the theme for all the uh
data science or all the machine learning
based analysis where you will have the
logic explained in the logic explained
and the power of this analysis explained
in the uh
turbo bioinfo platform setting and then
once you have understood what this
analysis can do to your data and how it
can be helpful and when you are
interested in learning how to achieve
such methods and how to analyze these
methods then you can use the associated
r lesson or python lessons to involve
python lessons to understand the
necessary
codes that are required to generate such
output methods so
i will stop here and ask if you have any
queries so far or i will quickly move on
to
clustering
uh yeah very quickly
so if you have uh no questions to follow
then no questions to uh ask then we will
go through there through
with what we have so far so uh so far we
have done um
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
analysis using principal component
analysis and spoke a little bit about
a lot about
dimensionality reduction techniques and
clustering analysis is actually
at its simplest form is is a task of
grouping a set of objects in in in a way
that the objects of uh same group or
objects that are found in this in one
group are
more similar to each other than those
are in the other groups so
the important aspect of this is
this approach seems to be
for example
deterministic as it
absolutely tries to find out
the association of each and every group
that the sample is associated with i
mean what do i mean by that if you have
an obvious outlier it tries its best to
accommodate that outlier into either one
of the clusters even if it means or even
if it reduces the accuracy of the
clustering so that is why this method is
deterministic and we have to be
extremely careful in applying this
method to some of the data that is
filled with outpace for example
here for yeah we know that from this
grouping these two are different uh
clusters from the color i think if you
can
look through the purple and orange color
so there are purple color dots here and
orange color does here and one green
color dots here but the clustering
analysis can very easily cluster all of
these together so and
and very easily cluster these together
where we will not have any problem
because most of the
participating uh samples are dots are
from the same color or same group so
that's what i meant by clustering
analysis being deterministic
so this is what yeah this is what it
finds um
obviously we will have
some
inaccuracies along the
intersection of two clusters along this
section where we have uh where the
boundaries are not uh defined properly
along the two clusters uh
so
what what does the data and how does uh
our how does the clustering
is performed from the structure the data
that we have so far so we have already
been going through this data for a long
time so let's take a look at our data so
we know that we can associate our data
with the different groups and groups in
this case are clinical subtypes of
breast cancer so where each gene has a
profile so each gene has a profile for
along the
samples that along across the different
sample types and these
data set as it can be see
as it can be
yeah i'm sorry about that uh
so
yeah yeah i muted and went to attend my
son sorry
so these genes as as we see will have
different patterns across different
samples so uh we cannot obviously plot a
bar plot for each and every uh sample so
in order to understand the patterns we
can actually use or employ a clustering
method so that the gene expression
patterns of all the samples inside those
uh
inside the specific clusters are defined
as a group that belongs or that
expresses the gene expression in in
specific patterns so that is what we are
going to find like for example when we
plot these bar plots along for this is a
limited data set like only 15 the genes
are given here so when we can find
patterns obviously but we can not do
this for
thousands and thousands of genes that we
have
so um there are different clustering
methods and algorithms that are
available for uh for uh depending upon
the data that we have uh in our hand so
i am not going to go over all of these
methods i am just telling you giving you
a heads up that we have different
methods of clustering and each and and
these methods will
actually depend upon the data that is
going to be used as addicted to
clustering
more often than not it's a very uh it's
a it's a it's an acceptable practice to
compare two or three different
clustering methods um uh for different
parameters that one can use to
judge these clustering options
so um hierarchical clustering is one of
the way is one of the popular approaches
to perform clustering because it uh it
actually has lot of options and allows
clustering at different levels usually
this algorithm uh does not require an
expected uh
or for example expected uh number of
clusters as it is often with a k means
clustering so it starts actually with
establishing uh hierarchy based on
closeness or based on the samples that
are closely related or close not close
related lets say if we have our samples
organized into some space or an
imaginary
2d plot let us say
these samples are positioned somewhere
in
in some perspective that best represents
the data variability so the algorithm
will first find
let's say two closest objects and then
link them together and then this is
called a cluster in in hierarchical
clusterings
algorithm and then
those
those two linked objects will become one
cluster and that will be represented by
only one one object or one sample and
then it does this iteratively to
include all the remaining data points uh
into either of the clusters that it had
already that it had calculated so far
for the data that we have so how does
that one work so the hierarchical
clustering
effectively does not require the user to
mention number of clusters beforehand
like it is usually the case with k-means
clustering but it gives the output in
the form that is called the dendogram so
that this is a dendogram where the
relation between samples are represented
as as a
as it as a as a
representation that is not very
dissimilar from phylogenetically uh
dendrograms so um
here we can use this data
yeah
sorry yeah this dendrogram to identify
how closely related a two clusters are
and this is how the clustering is
actually performed in ah hierarchical
clustering so that until
all the
samples are used up
into uh belonging to one or the other
clustering so this actually gives us a
hint on um
what are the necessary yeah let's not go
over this in each and every uh step of
this clustering method
i will quickly skip through
yes so what we actually
have is it calculates to do this it
actually calculates the pairwise
distances between the clusters and then
it uh constructs this uh using these
pairwise distances a distance matrix
from where um uh the algorithm can
identify pairs of clusters that are
closely
uh
closely situated or located and then it
continues to merge all of the samples
into clusters until we get one cluster
here so after the cluster analysis and
after creating these matrices after
getting the dendrogram one has to
mention i don't have to specify um how
many clusters do we expect to see from
um
see from our data analysis no it is not
related to nmds because um
nmds calculate it also calculates yes in
in some sense it also calculates
euclidean distances between the samples
but um
yeah in some sense you can say that it
is it is little bit related to nbs but
nmds
is structurally different from uh
hierarchical clustering in a way
that um hierarchical clustering uh
averages out that the distances between
two data points that nmds doesn't do it
just ranks each and every sample by its
relatedness or by its distance to other
samples
so but hierarchical clustering after
clubbing to a raptor making or creating
a cluster it calculates the centroid
for that cluster so which is the average
of
all the samples that are put together so
nmds doesn't do that so
how to set up clustering in uh in turbot
by info platform it is under
unsupervised analysis in a data mining
area
and you can you only need uh the
structure input file to go through
setting up turbo yeah setting up
the hierarchical question so again for
hierarchical clustering some of the
important set
parameters that you have to set is
to define the linkage
method and to define the distance with
which it is calculated and to
tell class tell how many clusters do we
expect but this number is actually used
only after creating or after calculating
the clusters or after calculating the
dendogram so
this is not employed before and before
creating the clusters like in k means
clustering
but this is done only after creating the
classes which can be changed after
calculating the clusters so
when we go
yeah when we move forward to uh
linkage method and distances and uh
different parameters so what is actually
linkage so a linkage is actually
finds
how
two or more clusters are actually linked
together and how they are
for example how they are how their
distances are calculated
then when you have an average linkage it
is going to calculate the distances
between these two clusters by
taking all of the cluster members into
account but when you have single linkage
that single linkage can be
distances between two closely related or
too closely located members and complete
linkage would mean distances between two
far away far apart uh situated members
and centroid linkage is another method
where it is actually calculating
decentralized so depending upon our
sample
we can use different linkage method to
either to get effective segregation and
uh to calculate uh different cluster to
calculate the clusters for our samples
so it is often useful to use different
distance method like euclidean licenses
that is the most used but manhattan
distances is also used and other
distance methods to
employ how the clusters arrangement
changes with respect to different uh
linkage methods and
sometimes each one of them will have
their own place in the data analysis
so uh this is
yeah selection is based on best yes
uh best cluster visually and how do we
evaluate cluster that is the next step
right we we got cluster that looks like
this the dendrogram that looks like this
and how do we evaluate the
accuracy of this gender graph so
obviously we have to
yeah this is this is as i mentioned if
you use for sorry if you use for
different
clusters after creating dendrogram the
cluster uh hierarchical clustering
identifies how many different types of
clusters that is
present in our
data or our data set so how to employ
clustering or how to in another
effective way how to interpret the
clustering so
essentially we will we can compare
actually how different and compared
contrast how clustering
is related to dimensionality reduction
techniques like pca and how it can
provide us with the very
useful insights about the data so in
this pc analysis you can obviously see
that
luminal groups are yeah just excuse
excuse me for a moment
okay i'm sorry about that so uh at it's
to interpret this pca plot we can easily
visualize and interpret that the luminal
samples are the ones that are far apart
or that there are segregated completely
from the other types of samples so that
is the essential
separation that we see in the uh
um
in the uh
dendrogram or hierarchical clustering
also but
in addition to this we can also see uh
yeah this separation is it can be
represented
in the
two major clusters that are observed in
our data set so in addition we can also
see
several
other
for example separation when you use
yeah when you uh employ uh
most distant uh um
samples like here the non-malignant
sample is the one that is the most
distant from the luminal sample that you
can see here also the non-malignant
sample is the one that is most distant
from the luminance sample as seen from
the pca variants so uh
yeah that yeah this we can see
and
so one of the good way as i mentioned to
test
what we see here is one of the good way
to test clustering is to
say to compare the phenotypes
that is that is associated with the
sample but can you tell me from this
data we have not been interacting for a
long time can you tell me from this plot
what is one thing that clustering will
give you or clustering output will give
you that pca will not so far in the past
two or three slides i am actually
comparing and contrasting the outputs of
pca and clustering and what is one thing
that clustering is actually providing
you with that pca will not give
selection is based on but yeah
no more queries i think everybody is
tired
so let's
move forward so uh clustering can also
give you distances can actually give you
estimated distances between the clusters
based on different uh parameters that we
have calculated so far but pca will not
give you the absolute distances so that
that we can use
and uh
yeah
so clustering uh can actually uh tell
you um
some of the surprises that you can see
for example in this specific case there
is a there seems to be an outlier but
this uh outlier is actually um a luminal
sample that has been uh completely
misinterpreted or mis identified with
and that is referred to
in this publication so clustering can
also
yeah clustering can also help us uh in
identifying um
samples that are oddly segregated or
located and then understand their
validation based on their
segregation due to the gene expression
pattern so clustering is is one of the
way
one of the widely used data
visualization technique where we can see
organized patterns in heat maps and we
can see um
gene expression data that is organized
as
as upregulated or down regulated set of
genes and these can be employed to
identify clustering in our samples and
visualize clustering in our samples so
far we have been talking about only one
more of hierarchy clustering there is
also other
types of clustering
so this is what i said
so different gene expression patterns
symbolizes or
effectively
creates different clusters that are
used for visualization and other
unsupervised
machine learning algorithm uh analysis
where you can identify patterns within
the data so this is also a data mining
method where
multiple different clustering methods
are available and depending upon the
method you will see um different
clusters being produced and
i think i hope you can see um yeah
so what i wanted to
represent here is it does not matter or
in in some sense the choice of the
clustering uh
might be obvious if you have a very good
data but
but most of the clustering will actually
uh have uh um
glaring difficulties in identifying or
in understanding the boundaries between
the uh clusters are and
locating the outliers that is present in
the clusters for example the
deterministic manner in which the
clusters are
generated require requires this
particular data to be part of this
cluster but we can definitely see that
this is completely far away and this is
an outlier so that is not the case so
these are the some of the difficulties
in using clustering analysis for um
for our
[Music]
machine learning or unsupervised machine
learning uh based techniques
analysis so uh these two points we have
to keep in mind we should not have
outlays in our sample and that can
easily be avoided by performing an
exploratory data analysis like pca and
another thing
we we might have some difficulties in
the
intersection between the cluster so when
you have
clusters that are closely related to
each other so one you you are bound to
find some inaccuracies there so one of
the way to combat that is to use a
different linkage methods and use
different
distance calculation methods to
find commonality between these
different techniques to
understand or to characterize these
clusters and there are also more
sophisticated way
to
for example
quantify the correctness or quantify the
accuracy of these clusters which which
is not
being discussed in this section so far
so um
so
until now we have been talking about
clustering based on gene expression
patterns that will cluster samples into
groups of or
into associated groups but you can flip
it around and you can transpose it and
find
and cluster the genes so that why it is
not going yeah quick quick
yes and cluster the genes to find uh
co-expressed clustering or genes that
are generally coexpressed together or
genes that share
similar expression levels
this is also widely used uh in in for
example in um
[Music]
in single cell rna analysis or in
metagenomics analysis to identify ah
common gene expression patterns and
other cases so um
yeah this is this is also widely used
case
so for example
when you use clustering across samples
it can
straightforward in a way
straightforwardly yield a very
meaningful output where you
see different
groupings based on the
gene expression pattern of samples but
depending upon your data
the clustering for genes might not yield
a very
straightforward or meaningful separation
so
you can use k-means clustering six or
seven or eight all of them will divide
this
this pattern into different clusters but
we obviously do not see um or we do not
see different
clusters in this specific distribution
so what do we do in that case so we have
to employ a different cluster methods
for this k means is not a best
clustering option as visualized
here and you have to employ something
like spatial clustering or other umap
and other clustering methods to
understand um
to understand
the clustering options that we have
so
i wanted to go over how
we can use clustering or how we can go
through the lessons of clustering uh in
um
in r in r and also in
in turbot bioinfo platform but i think i
briefly touched upon how we can go
through uh clustering methods in a turbo
buy input platform
since you get the
hang of how are lessons are
structured i think you can also
go through the clustering lessons in r
where yeah you can find the associated
lessons and i can take some questions if
you have any it's been a long long
session so far so let's quickly take a
couple of questions and uh yeah
we finished today's setup what type of
data used for input of clustering uh
okay that's an excellent we usually use
some sort of normalized data not raw
counts we use uh either log transform or
quantile either log transformed or
quantile normalized data okay
and
some in some sense you don't need to
normalize the data but normalizing the
data you only need it for
further other analysis because most of
the clustering method is going to
calculate the euclidean distances which
is completely
which is not
in a way yeah in a way it is dependent
on the scale that you have so it is
better to use log transform
data it is better to use log transform
data yes
so that is generally accepted as as a
good method because we normally or we
usually visualize the clustering on pca
and for pca you definitely need to scale
and center the data in some form of the
other so a log transform data is the
most used for clustering
so any other queries
yeah so go through the asynchronous
lesson tomorrow and day after tomorrow
we are going to deal with the further
exploratory analysis and i think we are
also going to deal with supervised
machine learning technique if there are
no questions then i will leave
the podium too sonalika to take over
thank you very much for your
participation
for a long time and yeah
i look forward to meet you all in
uh
yeah
day after tomorrow on thursday's session
if you yeah
yes sir thank you so much for the
wonderful session
and i would now like to re-share my
screen and let's discuss about the other
sessions and if you have not registered
yourself
then let's find a way how you have to do
so to get the access to to the resources
for a month
and also be a part of uh
second and third day of the workshop
so uh i'll just take a minute to reshare
my screen and i just want to make sure
uh one thing that this workshop is
definitely for three days
we had a wonderful uh first day today
and i
hope that you all had a great start and
then
able to learn more about machine
learning and its use for biomedical data
analysis
so now to
just a second
ragas can you confirm if my
screen is visible
okay thank you vipra
so i was telling you about the workshop
page and how you can register yourself
for the workshop and get the access to
omixlogic learn resources that includes
the coursework the bioml coursework r
and python that dr raghav went through
today and also either discussed about it
in the beginning of today's session and
also get the access to the t bio info
server and
work with your data set and on
using the machine learning utilities
and get a good hands-on practice
so
now to get an access to the other two
days of the workshop and to the
resources for a month
it's important that you register
yourself today was the first day it was
introductory day and that's why we
thought let's invite everyone who's
interested to learn about machine
learning
and uh have a look at what sort of
workshop this is all about so this is
the program page the link of which i've
shared in the chat and this program page
will help you look at the
uh content or let's see the session
details that will be covered in the
workshop
and
then on the work on the program page
itself you will be able to look at the
recordings of these sessions that i will
be having uh after being processed i'll
be uploading it up on the program page
and you'll have it uh with you for a
month that you can go through and
obviously it's not uh easy for all of
you to absorb so many things in just
three days so just go through these
resources like recordings coursework the
server practice pipelines at your own
pace
so uh
you you'll find all these resources
recording and also the associated
resource resources that you have to go
through a pair on the page itself
now indoor yourself for the workshop you
have three levels beginner intermediate
and advanced
in the beginner level you will get the
access to all these resources that i
just uh discussed the sessions that we
just had and be able to share questions
with uh dr rava
and if you would like to have a
one-on-one session maybe and then i
would suggest you go for an intermediate
type of subscription that will help you
um get in touch with dr raghav
and
have your questions answered and also we
have the symposium coming up it's in
march 31st and april 1st
so
um
taking the intermediate subscription
will help you get your seat saved for
symposium as well and you will be able
to be a part of the symposium and listen
to the great talks that we're going to
have from uh various international
institutions and universities and
industries as well
and so talking of which reminds me to
just quickly go through the symposium
page so that you don't miss out on this
opportunity and you can become a part of
the same
so this is
the symposium page the link is in the
chat box and on this page you can see
uh
what we are going to focus on right we
have mentioned the categories of our
symposium very clearly here on the page
itself and the speakers that were going
to have their institute institutions
what they're going to talk all about we
also have great researchers insiders
coming from
uh lsu amity and the industrial experts
from google faba prima's life sciences
and we'll be having some great talks
right
and if you would like to let's say be a
part of symposium only then i'll also
share the details with you so that you
can register yourself for the symposium
and save your seat and also we have
poster presentation competition in the
uh
symposium and the last day to submit
your abstract for the same is
20th march so if you are interested to
present your research work in the
symposium you can definitely submit your
abstract and i'll share the link with
you in the mail definitely
and you can proceed your application uh
in the form that will be given to me
the third option is an advanced level
not taking an advanced subscription
will help you get an extra time uh to
work on your research proposal
go through these resources discuss with
dr raghav and come up with a good
research proposal that you can work on
as an independent research project and
then definitely have a good outcome out
of it either a pre-print or a
publication or a review article or at
least a report that you can submit in
your college if you come from a
graduation or a post graduation
background and uh or uh you are in a
final year you will definitely require
to submit a project report maybe so
having this subscription will help you
in the same so these are the three
levels and if you are interested to pick
any one of these and become a part of
the workshop uh for a month then you can
reach out to us i put my um main address
in the chat box it's marketing and at
omixlogic.com
and the sales team on the business
development team if you inspire she will
be available uh when you mail on this
email id and she'll be able to help you
out with your enrollment and take your
application ahead
so that was all about uh the workshop
and the symposium if you have any
questions please put it in the chat box
so that
i can answer
any questions
okay so if you have no more questions
thank you so much everyone for
being a part of the session and we will
be looking forward to meet you tomorrow
thank you so much
dr drago for such a wonderful session
looking forward to your session tomorrow
thank you bye
you